if you're watching this video you are
likely playing Borderlands three and you
are interested in playing as flack now
they are a very interesting character
jean-luc why don't you give us a real
quick idea of who wants to play this
character you want to play as flack if
you are interested in headshot damage
you're interested in having an AI
companion that is going to do a ton of
damage for you or if you're into
non-binary robots that love asses that's
why I'm here
passes and kicking a button let's get
into what flak skill tree consists of
yeah so black has a hunter Master and
stalker and hunter is very much about
flack just dealing as much damage as
possible it's very focused on crit
damage master is very much focused on
blacks pets which I'll get to in a sec
and stalker is more about like a support
boosting flax health and fire rate and
stuff like that now as I mentioned they
have pets in addition to their three
skills they have three pets associated
with each tree you can technically mix
and match so you could go down one tree
and have a pet from a completely
different tree however the augments on
each tree are focused on augmenting the
pet associated with that tree so I would
recommend you pretty much stick with the
pet associated with that tree so on that
note which was your favorite tree and
what was your favorite pet so my
favorite tree that I went down was
hunter because I really was like I just
want to do as much damage as possible
and it's all about dealing crit damage
and just fighting tougher enemies like
there's a lot of cool abilities where
it's like when you fight multiple
enemies at the same time or you fight
tougher enemies it boosts how much
damage you're doing there are stuff like
galactic shadow which increases crit
damage but also makes enemies less
likely to attack you when you're going
down that tree you're focused on being
from a distance using long-range weapons
snipers assault rifles anything with a
scope because there are it's all about
just like that headshot damage so if you
like headshots then you want to go down
hunter its final ability mega voir is
really really useful it basically gives
a 20% chance that you will do a crit
regardless of body part
at that point once you've gone down that
tree you're probably already pretty good
at headshots but it then makes other
weapons more viable where you could fire
like a machine gun and you could still
be doing like crit damage potentially
with every shot which is really cool
with the hunter tree
the pet is useful but doesn't feel as
important he would be dying a lot and
I'd just be reviving him and I'm like
alright you don't seem as useful
it wasn't until I decided to respec and
mess around with the master tree that
I'm like the pet makes a lot more sense
because the master tree boost the pet's
health increases like shield damage it
made the pet feel more viable where I'd
like the pet was just doing damage and
actually killing people where before it
felt like down the hunter tree he was
just kind of there to like get shot at
while I could then shoot them he was
more like cannon fodder where with a
master he's actually like a useful
companion but what you're giving up is
that you yourself aren't as powerful and
you're in a you're really focused on the
pet I think there's a good balance where
you could combine those two pretty well
where you yourself could be doing lots
of crit damage from a distance and you
can have the master tree where your pet
is getting it up close and attacking
there's a really good guard slag is the
ability for the master tree and you
actually teleport your pet where the
enemy is and like they explode so you
can like teleport them from a distance
right into the action and then they can
be in the middle just mess and [ __ ] up
and then you can be way off in the
distance with your sniper rifle just
like picking people off and that's a
really good way to like combo those two
trees together the final tree stalker is
in my opinion the least useful is the
one I wasn't really focused on it's all
about just boosting health and fire rate
for flak and also flax pet as well but
it feels more like a complementary tree
that you would use with one of the other
ones afterwards
unless you're really new to Borderlands
and you feel like you're just dying a
lot I don't think that is the kind of
tree you want to initially invest in it
does have one really cool ability called
a lick the wounds that you get halfway
down where your pet can actually revive
you straight up which is really useful
especially if you're playing solo it
might be worth get to that point in the
tree halfway through but I would I would
try and focus on the other trees because
I think that's really
where you're gonna get the most use out
of flag so it sounds like you have to
make a choice with flack between
initially between crit damage pet
effectiveness and the ability to revive
yourself or escape situations exactly
yeah at least for the beginning once you
once you get enough points that you're
able to start investing multiple trees
that's when you can really like I'm
gonna be dealing damage and my pet
stealing damage or I'm dealing damage
and I'm able to heal myself but yeah you
can't have to make that choice at the
beginning so it's up to you personally I
took the damage route I think if you're
skilled player who likes getting
headshots that's gonna be the route for
you if you're more interested in having
the pet do a lot of the work I think go
down the master tree so you've talked a
lot about fighting from a distance what
weapons or weapon brands pair really
well with flack Jacobs guns that is the
name of the game there anything that is
about precision bolt-action put a scope
on it revolvers or great sniper rifles
obviously Jacobs guns have a lot of
really good like the assault rifles will
have like these bolt-action guns that if
you're really good with you can be
precise enough with that you can do
headshot damage even though they're
slower than the other guns the fact that
your crit damage is just gonna be so
high on like the the hunter tree you're
just gonna be doing so much damage that
it doesn't matter alright thank you for
watching if you're interested in other
Borderlands characters we have
individual guides on all of them as well
as a witch vault hunter is right for you
video that's a great overview of all
four together thanks for watching
[Music]
you
[Music]